let's do a little fill in the blank now
that we are more than halfway through
the top 40 quarterback countdown let's
reflect on
the first half the bottom 20. although
hey it's better to be in the bottom 20
than not on the list at all a couple of
fill in the blank topics as it relates
to those guys who were in the back half
of the countdown the hardest quarterback
to rank was who chris
oh
i think i would give that award to
taysom hill uh that was that to me and
on my list he's number 36 but again we
know what type of athlete and weapon he
is and he's very special that way you
know quarterback play
and projecting how he would be if he had
to play a you know
a a big number of snaps or a certain
number of games
you know yeah we're going on pre-season
film we're going on a few plays that we
see
you know spotty you know every few games
in in the regular season
and of course he hasn't had a long stint
or a long period of time experience you
know playing in the nfl right now so to
me that was one of the harder ones
because he has big time talent i think
you and i both see that we know he's
being coached by sean payton which is a
good thing as well so he's obviously
smart and capable of making decisions
and running the offense but
still
it's zero touchdown passes career in the
regular season in the nfl and it's a
minimal number of attempts so he was one
of the tougher ones i think for sure
and for me i i and i didn't do the
rankings but i think the hardest guys
and and this is taking your taste in
hill point and broadening it at least
we've seen taysom hill in an nfl uniform
we've seen him on an nfl field we have
the sense that he can at least pass the
eyeball test the guys who have never
played in the nfl how can you even begin
to project where they're going to fit
and you've got three of them if i'm not
incorrect and there's a chance i am
tuatang of iloa was at 40. justin
herbert was in the 30s and you had joe
burrow in the mid-20s i don't know how
you begin to do that when you don't have
any sample size any body of work
anything to give you confidence as to
where those guys are going to fit
relative to guys who have been in the
league and who have shown they can do it
no no i know that's the tough part and
you know hopefully that's where you know
the
the things i've learned throughout the
years growing up in the sport being
around it being in it uh i hope to be
able to lean on that type of knowledge
to where i can project that you know
again i'll i'll make the point here too
the year patrick mahomes was a rookie
that year got done and i made him and he
and only played that last regular season
of the game right and the last regular
season game of the year against the
denver broncos i made him a quarterback
like in the high 20s and people just
landed limb faced at me like you're
crazy he played one meaningless game
what are you talking about and you know
what i was crazy for i was crazy that i
didn't have them like 25 spots higher so
again you know i know it's not always
easy to do but some of these guys i've
seen enough whether it's jared stidham
herbert joe burrow guys like that and
i've been around enough to go yeah i
know they haven't played in the nfl but
i know from college and being around
quarterbacks my whole life that you know
these guys are better than guys i didn't
have on the list or guys that i have
behind them we'll see what happens when
they do get to play but uh yeah it's a
little bit of a projection some of them
no doubt about that
let's flip it around then the easiest
quarterback to rank in the bottom 20 was
who
well
none of them are easy i mean that's what
i really want to say i want to be like i
mean gosh everyone i'm sitting there
paying which was
the least difficult how about that yeah
the least difficult you know when i sit
here and just look at the list and the
one that i think i feel like i plugged
in pretty easily
okay
really and this is gonna is joe burrow i
had no qualms about joe burrow i got you
know he was kind of in that territory
right at number 26 where
it was
andy dalton ryan fitzpatrick's teddy
bridgewaters of the of the nfl those
type of guys you know and i was kind of
going okay what do i do here you know
between 26 and and 28 you know where
does he land but i i just think so much
of joe burrow and saw so many
nfl type plays and throws from him last
year at lsu
uh that that's
that to me was actually not a hard rank
for me it was not i i felt pretty good
about you know i think joe burrow is
clearly one of the 32 best quarterbacks
the day he steps into the nfl so
that actually did not was not that
painful for me you know other ones that
you know were somewhat easy or whatever
whatever it may be
um
i i guess i would look at like nick
foles around 30 and things like that
it's kind of just fell into place i
always looked at nick falls of dancing
around that nfl starter
nfl really awesome backup i'm not sure
but man none of these are easy mike i
stress out about this i still stress out
as you know going into the the day of
unveiling some of them and every now and
then and full transparency i think i've
done it maybe twice so far out of the
top 40
where you know i knew okay hey i got
this coming up and as i start to flush
it in my brain a little bit more i text
message pete demolitis like hey i might
swap you know switch these two guys or
or maybe just uh reorder you know one
guy and i think i've done it twice so
far but it's it's not an easy exercise
and definitely not
all right i would say that baker
mayfield would have been the easiest to
rank just because he's at 21. he played
last year as a guy who isn't a top 20
quarterback so number 21 because there's
hope they're going to turn it around in
cleveland and mayfield will do the same
thing if everything works the right way
and that leads to the next topic
if everything breaks right the
quarterback who could go the highest in
the top 40 next year is who
well
i look at drew locke as being one of
those guys just because i think he's got
phenomenal talent all right he you know
he's got a big time arm he can really
like make special plays with his ability
to deliver the football he's a good
athlete and then of course the support
system around them we know is improved
greatly coaches
and personnel so that would be one guy
to me that jumps off big time to where i
go hey drew lock could be one of those
guys that i wouldn't be shocked if he's
in the top 10 next year or dancing
around the top 10 in some capacity i'll
tell you another guy that i think could
be a riser
that i believe in and i know i know we
haven't seen them but jared stidham who
had a number 35 if i talk about any of
the guys who i think can make a huge
jump on this ranking as well maybe he
doesn't get in the top 10 but can make a
really significant big jump i do look at
him as a guy as well i think he's got
everything to be really successful nfl
quarterback and again he's being coached
well and i think he is plan a up there
in new england and they've improved
their weaponry a little bit too and of
course had some young guys who are going
to be going into year two that should be
improved as well so those are two guys
to me that i look at that could be big
risers next year you know
we've talked about
any of like to me the baker mayfield the
daniel jones the sam darnold i look at
any of those three guys with big time
potential to where hey they go out and
play some clean football and make some
plays they can all be risers but i think
you know stidhum and drew locke are
probably the two that jump out more to
me than any who who about who who do you
who jumps out to you
one name for me teddy bridgewater number
29 if everything breaks right he's got
christian mccarthy he's got dj moore joe
brady there with that understanding of
the new orleans saints offense doing the
things with bridgewater that sean payton
did last year when bridgewater was 5-0
and i think expectations are low there
are still people who think teddy
bridgewater is done
dating back to that horrific knee injury
from august of 2016. we have seen how he
has improved we have seen him play at a
high level the offense with enough help
around him designed in a way to take
advantage of his strengths minimizes
weaknesses i think bridgewater could end
up being a lot higher than number 29 by
the time it's all said and done because
the panthers are just one of those one
of those teams where and we don't really
expect all that much and every once in a
while it seems like every year there's
one of those teams that that has
everything fault into place and we say
after the fact boy how did we not see
that coming all right the least likely
quarterback to fall
next year in the top 40 based on where
he is now the least likely to fall is
who yeah right and i'm not gonna pick
like the guys up at like 35 or 36 or
whatever like that i'm gonna try to get
to some some
some guys or areas where we go okay that
could be a significant fall or whatever
it may be but daniel jones at number 22
would be a guy that i would be shocked
if he falls i would be i i just saw too
much consistency
you know too many great decisions too
many great throws
toughness in the pocket i know we talked
about him the other day his biggest
issue is being too tough in the pocket
being too
you know really
this is why
like if you listed problems a
quarterback has in the nfl that are
fixable daniel jones fumble problem is
one of the easiest fixes there is out
there it's really in a lot of ways
there's some positives but the way how
his size his athletic ability the fact
that the ball really he never loses
control of the football and he has a
strong arm to make power type throws
and you know he's obviously smart and
has good work ethic and really the
fumble thing mike in a lot of ways shows
me uh a kid who's like he's a good kid
he's trying to do what the coaches say
hey coach said go to one to two to three
and he's trying so hard to diagnose
what's going on down the field that he's
able to block out the mess within him
the pocket but that'll be an easy thing
for him mike to go back and watch film
and go oh okay here this is when i get
like a board mission a board mission i
need to get out of the pocket or do
something or throw the ball away he'll
learn that and he'll you can practice
that and do all of that so i think
daniel jones is a guy i look at to i
don't expect him to fall i expect him to
rise i'd be shocked if he falls
if they can in the control room throw up
the graphic of the 20 and i'll i'll i'll
throw a dart at one here that i think is
most likely to stay put i cool
i i would oh boy the least likely to
fall i would say is jared goff 24 is
about as low as you go as a guy making
33 and a half million a year it's only
up from here i'd be stunned if he's
lower than that next year and i'll tell
you what if he's lower than that next
year they better start figuring out who
their next quarterback is going to be in
la because if he's south of 25 as he
gets deeper into this 33 and a half
million a year contract that means you
screwed up and it's time to abort
yeah
that's fair and you know i probably
should have listed his name a little bit
as like one of those guys that was the
toughest to rank here in this you know
because you can get a little clouded by
the stats
and the wins right because we give the
quarterback the wins he gets all the
wins aaron does the winner then
he wins great other yeah he's a winner
all those other guys on rams hey screw
you guys you've done nothing
and i'm saying this not to take a shot
at jared goff or anybody like that but
just social media and yeah that's what
the people get on me about more than
anything and they point at like his
record or whatever he's done that way or
statistics and you know to me there's
more to that we could sit down and watch
film with jared goff and i'd go look
here's my concerns and i think people
would sit there and go yeah i get what
you're seeing now chris that makes sense
but uh it's tough sometimes to block out
that outside noise of winds and we saw
him in a super bowl and they've been
relevant and he's the quarterback and
sometimes we all fall on the track but
he must be awesome because their team
has been relevant
i'd like to think that we saw him in a
super bowl what we saw in the super bowl
would justify i mean three points for
the offense and yeah twice that play
that play twice they look i don't want
to go back and relitigate old issues but
my god they ran the play in the first
half and you didn't see brandon cooks
they had a half hour half time where
undoubtedly at some point in that 30
minutes they said hey when we used this
last last half it popped wide open we're
going to do it again it's going to pop
wide open brandon cooks are going to be
wide open why the hell did it take him
so long to see brandon cooks and then he
doesn't deliver the ball championship
throw championship moment it was goff
last year jimmy garoppolo this year that
separates the winner from the knot
winner you want to prove you're a winner
you got to make that winning throw when
it's time to go win a super bowl all
right it's time to take a break uh when
we return colin kaepernick making an
impact beyond the world of football
we'll tell you how when pft live resumes
right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports